let me just zoom out on human history
what makes Empires collapse and what
makes them last when they
do when you look at human history in
your
sense thinking about the United States
perhaps as an
Empire I don't view the United States as
an Empire uh what's the What's the defin
so to you Empire is a thing that seeks
expansion
constantly yeah I I think it's a country
uh that incorporates
different uh regions or areas around the
world uh into sort of a giant sphere of
influence without
incorporating those
territories actually into the state
itself so you had this thing called the
British Empire and it controlled areas
like
India uh
uh North
America uh and Kenya just to pick a
couple instances at different points
Singapore would be another example
Australia would be another example so
these were all entities that were part
of the British Empire right and the
United States has taken a stab at Empire
after the Spanish American war for
example uh with regard to the
Philippines and Cuba and Puerto Rico but
we never got serious about it there's
never been an American Empire this is
not to say the United States is not an
incredibly powerful country that goes
all around the world building military
bases and stationing troops Here There
and Everywhere but we're not running an
Empire the way the British Empire was
run or the French
Empire uh so the question for for me is
why did those Empires go away the why
did the British Empire go away if you
ever look at a map of the world in 1922
after World War I it's truly amazing how
much of that map is controlled by
Britain right they had a huge Empire and
it's disappeared probably by far the
biggest in terms of area Empire in human
history I think so I think that's right
it almost has to be yeah right right uh
crazy crazy yeah and then no longer no
longer is the case yeah now I I going be
clear the the Americans have
wielded maybe even greater influence
than Britain did when it had its Empire
but I don't believe we have an Empire
that bears any resemblance to the
British
Empire so the question is what happened
to that British Empire what happened to
the French Empire what happened to the
Belgian Empire what happened to the
Dutch Empire these were countries that
had colonies all over the Planet the
Dutch East Indies right Vietnam was you
know French Indochina where where did
those Empires go two factors finish them
off number one nationalism nationalism
became a very powerful force in the 19th
century it began to rear its head in the
late 18th century and became a very
powerful force in the 19th and certainly
in the 20ths can you explain nationalism
here nationalism is the idea that these
different nations that were part of the
Empire like the Kenyans wanted their own
State nation state this is my point
about the Palestinians right this is
Palestinian nationalism what is Zionism
Zionism is Jewish nationalism Jewish
nationalism think of Theodore herzl's
famous book it's called the Jewish State
nation state think of the word nation
state that embodies nationalism nation
state Jewish State Palestinians want
their own State two-state solution
right can't beat the Palestinians into
submission right the Indians wanted
their own State The pakistanis Wanted
their own State the Kenyans wanted their
own State Singapore wanted its own State
oh the Americans wanted their own State
this is called the American Revolution y
right so that's the first reason
nationalism that these Empires
disappeared the second reason is that
from a cost benefit analysis uh they no
longer made any sense uh and it was the
coming of the Industrial Revolution once
the Industrial Revolution comes an
Empire is basically an albatross around
your neck I would argue that the British
Empire was an albatross around Britain's
neck in most of the 20th century some of
my friends disagree with that and think
there were all sorts of benefits uh from
the British Empire but you want to
remember that in the 20th century the
three countries that really were
powerful were the United States Germany
and the Soviet Union those were the big
three did any of them have an Empire
no that's a good card in the industrial
world yes you don't need you know uh an
Empire right what you need is a powerful
manufacturing base well the the cost
benefit analysis is different before the
Industrial Revolution there's been many
empires there's no question that Empires
uh came and went right I mean yes right
and or you have to do is just look at
the British and the French uh in the
Seven Years War 1756 to
1763 the British win they get Canada
right and that's why you know Quebec
Montreal all these big French speaking
areas are now part of uh Canada right uh
so borders change and you know C
countries got established the United
States being one and remember South
America Central America were once
completely dominated by the Spanish and
in the case of Brazil the
Portuguese but uh they all in the 19th
century got their
independence right and what I'm saying
to you is in the 19th and in the 20th
century there were two forces that were
really driving the train one is
nationalism and then the other is the
Industrial Revolution which changes the
cost benefit
analysis